ah
a comienzos del siglo 19 muchos de
ustedes lo saben la suprema corte los
eeuu resolvió un famoso caso
marbury contra madison en ese momento la
suprema corte tuvo la genial intuición
de generar a la constitución como un
punto muy alto el más alto posible
dentro del orden jurídico los eeuu para
controlar la constitucionalidad de las
leyes
confrontó una ley contra la constitución
y esto me parece que es un avance
extraordinario en la civilización del
mundo varios años después hacia 1920
hans kelsen al crear la constitución
austriaca inventa un modelo distinto y
genera para el sistema europeo la
posibilidad de contrastar nuevamente las
leyes contra la constitución y hasta ahí
nos quedamos y así nos fuimos a la
segunda guerra mundial como humanidad
todos ustedes saben tuvimos uno de los
momentos más álgidos más complicados de
la existencia aparecieron fenómenos
los los holocaustos el alemán el
soviético y algunos otros en ese mismo
sentido cuando regresamos de ese periodo
tan terrible tuvimos también la fortuna
de que se creara un nuevo sistema
internacional
tuvimos declaraciones universales empezó
a una marcha muy importante para tener
tratados internacionales y la pregunta
que en ese momento se planteó es cuál es
el valor de los tratados internacionales
en particular el de los derechos humanos
frente a la constitución las
constituciones están arriba las
constituciones están abajo cómo se
armonizan cómo juegan entre ellas
tuvimos un período muy largo muy
complejo donde el concepto de soberanía
de los estados nacionales se oponía
precisamente a esta idea de reconocer
una jerarquía máxima a los tratados
hacia 1970 empezamos a
diluir esta fuerte posición de los
tratados y de la constitución en una
condición totalmente diversa y apartada
en el caso nuestro en el caso de nuestra
región con la corte interamericana con
la comisión con este trabajo tan
importante que se ha ido haciendo un
trabajo de a poco no pensemos que estas
cosas ni son fáciles ni son inmediatas
ni generan resultados para el mismo día
empezamos a disolver esta misma idea y
en distintos estados nacionales se
empezó a encontrar la forma primero de
armonizar después de establecer la
jerarquía igual un poco más arriba de la
constitución es decir como si fuera esto
una geometría unos balances unos efectos
diferenciados hasta que muy
recientemente hemos empezado a encontrar
como generalidad me parece en buena
parte del mundo que los tratados
internacionales en materia de derechos
humanos se encuentran en la misma
jerarquía que la constitución de los
derechos humanos de fuente
constitucional
se encuentran en una jerarquía superior
porque era muy importante hacer este
breve recuento porque el control de
convencionalidad se trata precisamente
les de la posibilidad de que los jueces
nacionales recibimos a cabo un control
de las normas de los actos que se dan al
interior de un estado nacional
utilizando como parámetro de referencia
como parámetro de regularidad los
propios derechos humanos contenidos en
los tratados internacionales y de esto
se trata el asunto pasamos entonces de
un control de constitucionalidad puro en
el sistema que yo me refería a la
sentencia marbury contra madison en el
sistema originario la constitución
austriaca de 20 hasta este sistema en el
cual los jueces de diversas maneras
ahora señala de cuales nos podemos
enfrentar con el tema de la violación a
los derechos humanos utilizando
y que estén establecidos en las propias
constituciones desde luego decir esto
que hay la posibilidad de un control
funcional que es la posibilidad de un
control de convencionalidad nos dice
mucho pero sin embargo nos queda un
problema muy importante y como es que al
interior de los propios órdenes
jurídicos nacionales las autoridades
judiciales pueden llevar a cabo este
control dicho de otra forma yo en mi
posición actual del juez de la suprema
corte de justicia a la nación de mi país
qué es lo que hago para efectos de darle
jerarquía validez posición y al final de
cuentas llevar a cabo un control de
regularidad constitucional si sé por
virtud de lo dispuesto en el artículo 1º
de la cocción que tengo que tomar
derecho de fuente constitucional y
derechos de fuente convencional en el
caso de rosendo radilla que resolvió la
suprema corte justicia de méxico en el
mes de julio del año 2011 encontramos
una solución que me parece es muy
es una solución moderna es una solución
flexible que nos permite darle de verdad
un buen entramado a estas dos
condiciones por qué razón
como muchos de ustedes saben en el
sistema jurídico mexicano teníamos hasta
esa decisión de manera muy clara
establecido un control que le llamamos
concentrado de constitucionalidad hasta
ese momento lo que hacíamos en el juicio
de amparo en las controversias
funcionales o en las acciones de
inconstitucionalidad es recibir una
demanda considerar el acto fuere este un
acto individual lo fuera este una ley o
una norma de carácter general y
contrastarlas contra un derecho humano
de la constitución allí lo que estábamos
analizando era la ley misma y la
respuesta que podíamos dar en esos tres
elementos era declarar la invalidez de
esa norma impugnada y desde luego
considerado inconstitucional en el caso
que estoy previendo por ser contraria a
la constitución y en particular a un
derecho humano y en el juicio de amparo
dejarla de aplicar
quien lo solicitó y en las controversias
y acciones declarar su
inconstitucionalidad
de manera general siempre que tuviéramos
ocho votos eso era lo que comúnmente
estábamos haciendo sin embargo en esa
sentencia del caso radilla sucedieron
dos fenómenos de la mayor importancia
uno en esos juicios de control
concentrado amparo controversias de
acciones también dijimos que podíamos
llevar a cabo la anulación de las normas
generales o de los actos siempre que
violaran un derecho humano contenido en
un tratado internacional celebrado por
el estado mexicano cuál es la
importancia de esto que frente al
control de constitucionalidad pasamos
también al control de convencionalidad
desde entonces la suprema corte de
justicia está declarando no muchas
también hay que decirlo pero si algunos
casos relevantes la invalidez de normas
generales o actos precisamente tomando
en cuenta el contenido de esas
disposiciones constitucionales
en un par de casos de magníficos desde
mi punto de vista un traslado de presos
de zacatecas veracruz y una condición de
trabajos forzados en el estado de
campeche la suprema corte se presta se
presentó frente a sí los derechos de
fuente ecuación al los derechos de
fuente convencional y vio cuál de estos
dos eran el más protector y género
entonces su protección anulando los
actos que habían sido impugnados pero
adicionalmente en esa misma sentencia se
reafirmó algo que había ido apareciendo
esporádicamente psíquicamente si ustedes
quieren en el orden jurídico mexicano
que era el control difuso es decir la
posibilidad de que cualquier juez de
nuestro país pero más allá de los jueces
de amparo llegarán a desaplicar al caso
concreto que estuvieran juzgando una
norma de carácter legal prioritariamente
que fuera contraria no sólo a un derecho
humano de fuente constitucional sino
también a un derecho humano que
estuviera contenido en
constitucion que quiero decir entonces
que en nuestro país hoy en día y
afortunadamente lo que estamos viendo es
una dinámica jurídica completamente
distinta donde este control de
emocionalidad y este control de
convencionalidad se han insertado de
manera plena en el propio orden jurídico
hoy en día los jueces federales del
poder judicial de la federación o
federales el tribunal de justicia
administrativa las todavía existentes
juntas de conciliación y arbitraje o los
jueces de las entidades federativas
podemos cuando se nos presente un caso
donde esté impugnado una norma de manera
directa a un acto frente a un derecho
humano de fuente constitucional o de
fuente internacional de fuente
convencional llevar a cabo entonces
estos ejercicios para proteger de la
mejor manera posible los derechos
humanos de las personas yo creo como
muchas otras personas que el derecho
tiene una función al final de cuentas
civilizatoria al final de cuentas lo que
el derecho nos permite es una condición
de convivencia entre todos nosotros y en
los tiempos que estamos viviendo el
paradigma general la manera general de
organizar nuestra convivencia es a
partir de los derechos humanos ya
sabemos que históricamente no siempre ha
sido así
no sé qué vaya a depararnos el futuro
este es un tema extraordinariamente
difícil de predecir lo que sí queda
claro es que en este momento histórico
existe esta idea general de protección
de fuente constitucional y de fuente
convencional ahora bien en nuestro país
por una tradición puede ser
internacionalista o por una ansia de
encontrar legitimación a los distintos
regímenes políticos que hemos tenido no
siempre todos ellos de carácter
plenamente democrático se han firmado en
nuestro país un sinnúmero de tratados
internacionales que problema interesante
nos plantea la convencionalidad
encontrar una especie de regla de
reconocimiento no en el sentido de un
profesor inglés de enorme importancia
pero sí en el de saber cuando en un
tratado internacional celebrado por el
estado mexicano que no tenga en
principio la vocación de derechos
humanos no la convención o los tratados
etcétera que no tenga en principio esta
vocación podemos identificar un derecho
a este me parece que es una tarea
importantísima para los próximos años
ejemplo es posible en un tratado de
aguas en un tratado de libre comercio en
un tratado de doble tributación
encontrar derechos humanos o no es
posible esto si es posible como bajo qué
regla
bajo qué concepto lo podemos identificar
traer al orden jurídico para efecto de
hacer operaciones con el mismo y
proceder a la protección más amplia de
las personas este me parece que es un
problema importante de la
convencionalidad de nuestro tiempo un
segundo problema igualmente interesante
el de es el de saber cómo vamos a jugar
con los derechos humanos de fuente
constitucional y de fuente convencional
cuando tengamos que hacer operaciones
jurídicas cotidianamente
si yo lo que tengo es una reclamación de
un sujeto que me dice y regreso al caso
del traslado de presos de zacatecas
veracruz que lo que él quiere es
regresar a su lugar de origen o estar en
la prisión
donde originalmente fue puesto que es lo
que debo hacer yo me debo plantear el
contenido del artículo 18 que tiene todo
el sistema de reinserción social y
simultáneamente tengo que buscar en la
totalidad de los derechos humanos que
estén celebrados por el estado mexicano
cuál es el más protector de la condición
de las personas que estén privadas de su
libertad lo interesante de nuestra
constitución también en este juego de la
convencionalidad es ponernos frente a
nosotros como juzgadores el mayor
derecho o la mayor protección que genera
un derecho por la constitución y la
mayor protección que genera un derecho
por la convención por un tratado
internacional poner los dos juntos
buscar cuál es el que mayor protección
genera y aplicarlo eso para precisamente
darle la mayor satisfacción posible a
esta persona este me parece un ejercicio
importantísimo que desafortunadamente no
siempre no todos estamos haciendo en
nuestra calidad de juzgadores
como me parece estar del todo
explicitado en los ejercicios académicos
y en los ejercicios legislativos y en
distintas formas de producción del
derecho en nuestro país también me
parece esto una cuestión interesante y
la tercera como un reto también muy
importante es cómo motivar a los jueces
que no tienen en principio una vocación
de protección a los derechos humanos
porque lo suyo es conocer procesos
civiles mercantiles familiares laborales
etcétera para que inicien este trabajo
importante este trabajo de protección
que aprendan a tomar el ámbito del
derecho ocasional el ámbito del derecho
convencional hagan un ejercicio en este
sentido y logremos de verdad entre todos
la mayor protección de estos derechos la
disciplina de la política la disciplina
del ejercicio del poder en general y le
demos esta condición de protección a los
habitantes del territorio nacional creo
que con estas ideas
he tratado de explicar al menos una idea
general de la convencionalidad una idea
general de la protección y les agradezco
mucho a todos ustedes su atención muy
buenas tardes